- So the final keynote address--
I'll just try to glue the two--
the last panel
and this together.
So I've seen Chris
talk in the spring
at the new aquarium about
whales and noise pollution,
and I was thinking,
how could we look at--
could protect this resource?
And I was out sea
kayaking off of Cape Cod
with one of these
VHF transceivers,
and when I get bored
when I'm sea kayaking,
I just turn it on and listen to
the chatter of what's going on.
And I heard frequently
that the Coast Guard would
come on and advise
that there would
be a right whale
somewhere and would
caution mariners to stay
away from the location
of the right whale.
So they have a certain function
in protecting marine resources.
So we're lucky today to
have the Rear Admiral here,
and to introduce him
is Richard Lazarus, who
is a professor of law
here at the law school
and he specializes in
environmental and natural
resource law.
Richard.
- Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, it's my great
pleasure and my honor
to introduce Rear Admiral Steven
Poulin at Harvard University
and welcome you here and
to the Radcliffe Institute.
Rear Admiral Poulin
assumed the duties
of Commander of the First Coast
Guard District in May 2016,
in that capacity overseas
11,000 active duty reserve
civilian and auxiliary personnel
who perform Coast Guard
missions across the eight
Northeastern states,
including over 2,000 miles of
coastline of the United States.
He served in a variety of
legal governmental affairs
and personal operational
assignments in the Coast Guard
including command
ashore as well.
He also served as
special adviser
to the vice president
of the United States,
as well as the Coast
Guard's liaison
in the State Department's
office of ocean affairs.
And with that, I welcome you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- It's a tremendous honor
for me to be here today,
and I'm truly humbled that I
have the privilege of providing
the closing remarks for this
productive and informative
symposium.
The exchange of ideas
and our dialogue
will certainly make a difference
in protecting our oceans.
Before I get started, just
because we had a kayak story,
I'd be remiss as a
Coastie if I didn't
say I hope that you wear your
personal flotation device carry
a light.
And you-- good.
Very good, very good.
You know, I really
enjoy getting a chance
to see the posters
over the lunch break.
So I commend all the scientists
and the scholars that
did all the hard work and put
together that great research
and analysis.
It's truly inspiring.
As a Coast Guard officer,
I took a very keen interest
in the study concerning
ocean locomotion.
There was also a study
on the use of robotics
to aid in search and rescue.
There was one presentation
on the mapping
of genetic resources, and I
know that's a very big issue
that we're dealing
with internationally.
The rights of the
genetic resources
beyond national boundaries
is a very hot topic.
And there were a lot
of other presentations.
I was also struck by
the great work that's
being done on the pressures
and impacts of ocean vortexes
on risers if I understood
the analysis correctly.
I was a incident commander
during the Deepwater Horizon
oil spill.
I was down there from the
time the Deepwater Horizon
exploded until we
turned the lights off.
At the incident
command post in Mobile,
I was responsible for
clean-up operations
in Mississippi, Alabama,
and the Florida panhandle,
so that certainly is something
that I took great interest in.
I think it's
important that we all
continue to push our
thinking and our innovation
on ways to tackle the
stress on our oceans
from increased global
competition, greater
exploitation as well as
emerging issues such as warming
water, rising sea
levels, and pollution,
and I'll talk a little bit about
marine pollution here in a bit.
We must ensure that we're
good stewards of our oceans
and that we do all that we
can to ensure sustainability.
So I congratulate and
thank Radcliffe as well
for sponsoring this symposium.
It's very timely
and absolutely what
we need to catalyze action,
so thank you very much.
So why after a full
day of listening
to astonishingly smart
scientists and scholars
am I here?
I'm neither a scientist
nor am I an academician,
although I did stay at a
Holiday Inn Express last night.
I couldn't resist, guys.
I just couldn't resist.
Honestly, I am a bit
intimidated to be here in front
of such distinguished
scientists and scholars
because I got a D in
calculus, and that's
one of the reasons I
decided to go to law school.
I knew I would never
have to calculate
the area under a curve
in practicing law.
The good thing about being
a lawyer in the Coast Guard
is that we're all line officers
unlike the other military
services, so we
get the opportunity
to get out to the field
and do hands-on Coast Guard
operations, which is what brings
me to Boston as you heard.
What brings me to the
Radcliffe Institute
here today is my hope that I can
provide some context, perhaps
even a new perspective on
the need for cooperation
and collaboration in
protecting our oceans.
My further hope is that
I can share some insights
on how we as a community can
collectively manage the oceans.
Just to set the
framework, I believe
that the key is committed
partnership and cooperation.
The pillars of this effort must
include individuals, industry,
science, academia,
governments of all echelons,
and non-governmental
organizations.
All of these will
play an essential role
in ensuring the
vitality of our oceans.
The Coast Guard is a
nation's federal Maritime law
enforcement agency, we're an
Environmental Protection Agency
and we're the nation's
Maritime first responder.
We also safeguard and facilitate
safe Maritime commerce
and Maritime activity.
Obviously then, changes
in the ocean environment,
changes in climate patterns
are of great interest to us.
We need to be agile enough
to adjust to these changing
conditions to continue to
do what America expects
of its Coast Guard, and
I should say what America
expects of your Coast Guard.
So I'm going to ask
your indulgence first.
It helped me give you a
thumbnail sketch of the Coast
Guard.
I find that most people know
a little bit about the Coast
Guard because of such
personal interaction,
but perhaps you don't know the
comprehensive picture of all
that we do as an organization.
The Coast Guard is
a military service.
We reside in the Department
of Homeland Security.
This is a snapshot
of our workforce.
41,000 active duty
personnel, which
is just a little bit larger
than the New York City Police
Department if you
can believe it.
And then we have 8,000 members
of the federal civilian
service, and I'm very thankful
that we have the surge
capacity of 7,000
reservists who have
the status of reserve members
of the other military services.
And we have 30,000
civilian volunteers
who we call auxiliarists.
You saw one earlier today asking
a question in this full Coast
Guard regalia, so it
was neat to see that.
I should also say
that we're hiring.
So if you want to enlist,
please come up and see me.
I know it's a shameless plug,
but I'd be remiss as a Coastie
if I didn't ask you to join up.
And as you can see, our core
mission is making pizza.
[LAUGHING]
As much as we like pizza, our
core responsibility in reality
is to ensure
America's sovereignty
along 95,000 miles of US
shoreline and the associated
territorial sea, as well
as to protect America's
sovereign rights throughout
that 3.4 million miles
of our exclusive economic zone.
While our name
Coast Guard suggests
that we operate
in the littorals,
it's somewhat of a misnomer.
We are globally deployed and
we operate as far out to sea
as possible.
When it comes to intercepting
threats to America's homeland,
we want to play an away game.
We don't want to play
goal line defense.
When it comes to
Maritime threats
and transnational
organized crime,
we intend and we do project
effective presence offshore.
Now we have 11
statutory missions,
and it would take me
all of my allotted time
to discuss the parameters
of each of those missions
with you.
I think it's better
that I just sort of
give you a summary
of what we do.
And here it is broken down
into three general categories--
Maritime safety, security,
and Maritime stewardship.
But even those are hard
to get your arms around,
so what I like to say
is we protect America
from threats delivered by sea,
we protect those on the sea,
and that we protect
the sea itself.
I think that's a much more
understandable way of knowing
the Coast Guard and what we do.
It's that third mission
that I want to talk mostly
about today, and that is
Maritime stewardship--
protecting the sea itself.
And when I talk about
Maritime stewardship,
I'm talking about marine
environmental protection
and I'm talking about
our responsibilities
for living marine
resource enforcement.
Now I bared my soul to you about
my lack of scientific prowess,
and I'm going to step carefully
into some scientific data
that I feel is very compelling.
Now it's not my work.
If it were my work, it would
be D quality as we all know.
And I think the prior
panel did a much better job
than I could ever dream of doing
in talking about what we're
seeing up here in New
England with respect
to migration of fisheries
and warming ocean trends,
but it's in my
slide presentation.
I'm going to do it anyway.
This is not my data.
The credit goes to Pinsky
Lab at Rutgers University.
It goes to Noah's National
Marine Fisheries Service,
the Connecticut Department
of Environmental Protection,
and the Millstone
Nuclear Power Plant.
The first data set that you see
is from Connecticut Department
of Environmental Protection.
It reflects their analysis of
temperatures on Long Island
Sound, and these
are temperatures
that were reported by the
Millstone Nuclear Power
Station.
Regulations require them
to report temperatures
twice daily, and this is
the trend from 1976 to 2015.
And I know again this is maybe
a difficult curve to read,
but what it shows is this.
The blue lines starts at
76 and go through 2015.
The green line, which is above
the bell curve of the blue,
is reflecting
temperatures of 2012.
And then the red bell
curve is reflecting
the 2015 temperatures that
started lower, but then went
higher.
In essence, what
this graph shows
is empirical data that
water temperature trends
in Long Island Sound
are getting warmer,
or is in 2015 experiencing
lower lows but higher highs.
The next slide shows the
changing distribution
of lobsters over
time, and I think
it validates the temperature
readings from Long Island
Sound.
And I think it also validates
what you heard earlier.
The Pinsky Lab at
Rutgers analyzed data
that NOAA's National
Marine Fisheries
Service had been
collecting for years,
and I believe these results
were quite traumatic
when you look at the trend.
The red reflects the
higher density of lobster,
and the blue are
lower density looking
at the comparison between the
'70s to the '90s, to 2015.
I think it's clear that
the lobsters are migrating
North and East in general.
And as I understand it, the
current scientific explanation
is that lobsters are moving
to remain in colder water
as that water trends North.
And just as another
data point perhaps,
Connecticut used to land about
3.7 million pounds of lobster
a year, worth about
$12 million in 1990.
But in 2014, that
amount diminished
to about 127,000 pounds.
Now to show you that this isn't
just about lobster as we heard
earlier, this is also about
trends in other species
such as black sea bass.
This shows the movement
from Maryland, Delaware
starting in the '70s,
steadily moving northward
up into New England by 2015.
Again, the point
is that marine life
is adapting to ocean
temperature change
by migrating North and East
to remain in cold water.
Now one of the other reasons why
I wanted to show you this data
was not so much to show
you the trends-- as I said,
others could do that
much better than I.
But it's to reinforce the
point that partnership
and collaboration is essential
because this data was
assembled, compiled, and
represented by the great work
and collaboration of
industry, state, academia,
and federal agencies.
The sharing of scientific
study, data, and information
is a critically
important element
in managing our ocean resources.
Sharing information will
always have a unifying effect
that I think will promote
a common understanding
of the challenges and
trends in the oceans.
They'll forge
consensus on solutions
and allow us to assess and
forecast effectiveness.
Now I understand the
sharing of technology,
the sharing of
proprietary information,
sharing of intellectual
property is a sensitive issue.
That's not what I'm advocating.
What I'm advocating
is that we maximize
our shared learning and our
understanding of ocean science.
That we seek to expand
our circle of discussions
that engage the broad
set of stakeholders
that I mentioned earlier.
Frankly to me as a layman,
there are disparate views
among stakeholder groups
as to the nature and extent
of the stress on
our oceans, which
also leads to disparate
views on solutions.
I think expanding
information and sharing will
build confidence and consensus.
I was in St. John's,
Newfoundland,
this week to talk
about Maritime safety
and security in the Arctic.
It was a symposium that brought
together industry, academia,
and governments to talk
about how we improve safety,
security, and
environmental preparedness
and response in the Arctic.
The Arctic's a strategic
imperative for many nations,
so there has been much
study and attention
paid to it in recent
years, especially
over the past decade.
What I found refreshing
about that symposium
was that all of us
who spoke had a shared
understanding of the
problem set in the Arctic.
The rising sea levels,
the loss of permafrost,
increased shipping and
other man-made activity,
remoteness and the
tyranny of distance,
and the lack of infrastructure.
Our shared understanding
of the problem
allowed us to then focus our
energy on discussing solutions.
For the Coast Guard, we followed
President Obama's lead in 2013
and published our own
supporting Arctic strategy
and implementation plan.
Our strategic objectives in the
Arctic, which is ocean space,
is first to improve our
awareness of all the activity
both man-made and natural that
is occurring in the Arctic.
To modernize governance,
which I think in part
is to ensure that we can
project an effective presence
in that part of the world.
The Arctic is not a new
operating environment
for the Coast Guard.
We have been up there off Alaska
since Alaska was a territory.
But as we know, the
challenges are growing
and the need for a Coast
Guard presence is growing,
and we must be able to
modernize our governance.
And the last underscores
the point and the theme
of my discussion
here, and that is we
need to broaden partnerships.
Now our Coast Guard motto is,
"Semper paratus," always ready.
And in order to maintain
that high standard,
it's important that
we work with others.
And in today's world of
constrained resources
and rapidly shifting
complex matters,
the Coast Guard simply
can't do it alone.
Ensuring safety, security,
and environmental responsible
maritime commerce and
activity are important goals,
but it's not solely a
Coast Guard responsibility.
It's a shared responsibility
for all of us.
We have to all
recognize that we are
actors in the continuum of
actions related to the ocean.
Take for example the
movement of the vessel.
I view this as a continuum
of critical linkages
that involves the shipping
company, shippers,
Maritime agents and insurers,
the crews, and the government.
There are many more
actors in the chain,
but I just wanted to give you--
sort of paint a picture for you
by highlighting a few of what
I consider the key actors.
Each element in the chain
is a critical link that
has an important role to play.
Now if you noticed,
I put governments
at the end of that chain
because while I believe
government oversight
is important,
it should not be viewed as the
primary means of compliance
to sound Maritime practice.
Governments cannot be seen as
guarantors of safety, security,
and stewardship because frankly
the chain is just too big
and it's too long.
We must rely on the
greater guarantee
that each link in the
chain will do its part.
We need to rely on
shipping companies
to put in place good
business practices
and have robust compliance and
oversight programs themselves.
Crews must be well-trained
and they must understand
the responsibilities.
They need be empowered by their
companies and their officers
to take action, to
mitigate safety, security,
and environmental
risks, including
being empowered to come forward
and report discrepancies
and violations.
And absolutely yes,
governments need
to fulfill their obligations
as flag states, coastal states,
and port states.
This continuum needs to
be a culture of shared
responsibility, and I think
that shared responsibility
is made easier the more we
collaborate and exchange
information and best practices.
Let me turn to marine
environmental protection, which
is perhaps the most visible
and obvious area where we
have a shared responsibility.
Preservation of our
oceans means that we
must tackle persistent
noncompliance
with pollution prevention laws.
In 2014, we investigated over
3,600 pollution incidents
in our navigable
waterways-- 3,600.
We conducted more than
25,000 inspections
on hazardous
materials containers,
and we found over
5,000 discrepancies
that if left uncorrected could
have impacted our waterways.
And we also continue
to find vessels
intentionally disabling or
bypassing required pollution
prevention equipment.
And frankly, this
issue confounds me.
Now criminal referrals
vary from year to year,
but overall we have not
seen a decrease over time.
In 2015, we had 16
criminal referrals
for environmental
violations and we
save those criminal referrals
for the most egregious
of cases, and that was up from
15 referrals a year before.
When we do the math,
only about 0.15%
of all compliance boardings
lead to criminal referral so let
me be clear.
I think that the vast
majority of Maritime industry
are good environmental
stewards and they're
serious about
environmental compliance.
I'm not here to suggest
otherwise-- far from it.
I've seen vast improvements
across the spectrum
of the Maritime sector, but
it's an unfortunate reality
that some companies
and some individuals
are unwilling to comply.
And I said this is an important
responsibility to the Coast
Guard.
We cannot do it alone.
We count on the
committed support
from other criminal
investigators
and also the
Department of Justice
who litigate these cases for us.
Now I was part of the early
efforts in the Coast Guard
where we tried to spur greater
environmental compliance
through launching
criminal referrals.
Before that, we relied mainly
on administrative sanctions
and other measures.
And we thought that it would
be a temporary program.
Well, much to my regret, we're
still in this line of business
and I don't want to be.
We're seeing time and
time again that we're
referring the same
kinds of cases
to the Department of
Justice for criminal action,
and it's the same pattern--
dumping oil, falsifying record
books, and lying
to the Coast Guard,
and encouraging others
to lie to us as well.
It just doesn't make
sense in my mind
why there is still a
subculture of noncompliance
in some segments in
the Maritime industry.
I don't know why people,
companies would put themselves
at risk and my
crew members would
put their own liberty at risk.
Now I appreciate that the
reasons for non-compliance
could be complex.
But since the 1990s when
we launched this program,
companies have paid
over $330 million
in vessel pollution fines.
We banned vessels from calling
at United States ports.
People have gone to prison.
Companies have had to implement
environmental compliance
programs, they've had to do
audits, there are legal fees.
There are significant costs
associated with noncompliance,
yet again we aren't seeing
a decrease in referrals.
So let me be clear-- we
have a continuing problem.
But I think it's
also clear that if we
meet our responsibilities--
that shared responsibility--
and each part of that continuum
of compliance does its part,
we can change the subculture.
Now you may ask, what can I do?
I'm not in the
shipping industry.
I'm not an enforcement agency.
How is this relevant to me?
Well, I think we must
continue to rely on science
and we have to rely on
academia to help us develop
the technologies, the
processes, and protocols to help
meet environmental standards.
And I could give
you a full array
of examples when I'm just
going to give you a few
to highlight my point.
The first is we need to develop
good oil spill detection
technology.
We need to stimulate
oil spill technologies--
oil spill cleanup
technologies especially
to address heavy oils
that sink and not flow.
We need technologies
to neutralize
aquatic nuisance species.
We need capabilities to expand
our Maritime domain awareness.
And we need metrics
for assessing
the effectiveness of enforcement
on preserving the biomass.
Now my hope again is that we'll
close this line of business,
but the only way we can
do that is with your help.
and with that shared
responsibility
that I mentioned.
Protecting and sustaining
living marine resources,
or more commonly what we call
fisheries, is a global concern.
We face multiple
challenges in our fight
to ensure sustainable
fish stocks.
We've heard throughout this
symposium about trends,
we've heard about the
migration, we've heard
about diminishing fish stocks.
Frankly, part of the problem
is us, the global population
that consumes fish.
The demand for
protein's growing.
It will continue to grow
geometrically, I suspect.
More than three billion
people, many of whom
live in the least
developed countries,
rely on food from the ocean as
their most significant source
of protein.
And more than 50 million people
worldwide make their living
based on the fishing industry.
And again, I believe the
vast majority of those
are good stewards and want a
sustainable fishery to maintain
their quality of life.
However, even here
we're seeing significant
noncompliance, predominantly
illegal, unreported,
and unregulated fishing.
Known as IUU fishing.
And according to the UNFAO,
the Food and Agricultural
Organization, about 15% to
30% of global annual catches
are the result of IUU fishing.
And it presents a direct
threat a direct threat
to not only global economies,
but I think global stability.
And we're at the forefront
of this challenge.
We're trying to meet
it head on here,
not only projecting our
own presence as we do here
in the First Coast
Guard district,
but also working
with our partners
and through the various
international fisheries
organizations.
As we say in the
Coast Guard, we want
to take a round turn on this
problem and get ahead of it,
but we can only do that
with a committed support
of our partners.
The other thing
that we need to do
is we need to rely on our
scientists and our academicians
and our scholars to help
us better project trends.
We need to better
target our resources
for fisheries enforcement.
We can't afford to
simply turn a screw
and punch holes in the ocean.
We need to do targeted
enforcement because resources
are limited, and
we need your help
in defining those
metrics so that we
know that we're putting
effective resources on top
of the problem to ensure that
we have sustainable fish stocks.
Now part of "Semper paratus,"
our motto, "Always ready,"
means that we have to
take a hard look at what's
coming at us in the future.
And of course, we're very
mindful of the trends
that we're seeing in
the Maritime domain
through climate change
rising sea levels.
We're the Maritime
first responder agency,
so of course we are very
concerned about what
the effects will be
on storm predictions,
and the severity in number of
storms we may see in the future
because part of
our responsibility
is ensuring the resiliency
of the marine transportation
system.
But we are the Coast Guard.
We operate and
live on the coast.
Our units are on the coast.
Our infrastructure
is on the coast.
And I recall a discussion that
I heard our commandant, Admiral
Zukunft, talked about recently.
He was talking about
his recent visit
to Greenland with
Jakobshavn Glacier,
and he talked about how
that glacier has receded
25 miles in only the past five
years and the dire predictions
that sea level could
rise up to 2 meters.
And then he also talked about
the National Snow and Ice Data
Center in NASA's announcement
that Arctic sea ice
set a record low in March
for the lowest winter maximum
in the satellite record.
And while the lowest maximum
winter doesn't necessarily
mean we're going to see the
lowest minimum in summer,
it certainly doesn't bode well.
The trend's becoming more
and more clear I think,
and we are taking note of it.
So it goes beyond just the
impact of warming oceans,
on fisheries, and the trends
of migrating fish stocks.
It goes beyond the displacement
of indigenous populations
in Alaska which rely on Coast
Guard support and protection.
It goes beyond what we're
seeing with some Pacific Island
nations.
Fundamentally, it goes to the
Coast Guard's ability to remain
"Semper paratus"--
always ready--
to respond to emerging threats
as we see sea levels rise
and encroach upon our
critical infrastructure.
So we are very much focused
on planning forward.
Now this is somewhat
of an eye chart here
and it's not my intent
to have you read it all.
It's simply my
intent to give you
a snapshot of what
Maritime activity looks
like in part of my
area of responsibility
here up in the Northeast.
These are competing, often
conflicting and overlapping
waterways uses, and it
creates a real conundrum
on how you make sure that the
waterways remain safe with all
of this growing complexity.
And frankly, one
of the ways we're
trying to address
this complexity
is through the
Northeast Regional Ocean
Council, or NROC for short.
The group was formed
over a decade ago in 2005
by the New England
governors who then invited
federal agencies that
have particular expertise
and relevant authority
like the Coast Guard
to come together to discuss
these regional ocean issues.
And again, it was
prompted by the complexity
of a very dynamic
operating environment.
As I said, quite a
conundrum for us.
Again, another eye
chart and I apologize.
This is a snapshot of
the kind of complexity
in the offshore environment.
The NROC did a great job in
launching a data portal that
provides access to critical
information for agencies
and stakeholders such as us
to better plan and execute
our responsibilities.
This happens to show the portal
for the offshore environment.
Again, another snapshot
from the portal on what
traffic trends look like.
In the previous panel, it showed
sort of global traffic trends.
This kind of data--
this sharing of data,
this sharing of
information helps us better
plan and allocate our resources.
We need to stay ahead of the
power curve, and the best way
to do that is to have good,
solid, sound scientific data
to stand behind as we allocate
those scarce resources.
And the federal
government finally
caught up with the
New England governors
and a presidential
executive order
was issued to establish both
the national ocean council
and regional advisory councils.
The one for New England here is
called the Northeast Regional
Planning Body.
Since the NROC was
already established,
the NROC basically was
leveraged as the entity
to meet that presidential
directive and the entity
to develop the
Northeast ocean plan.
It was due in large part
to the NROC's existence
that New England was the
first region in the nation
to respond to a presidential
executive order.
And this Northeast
ocean plan is meant
to strengthen inter-agency
coordination while enhancing
the public's ability
to participate
in the process of
managing resources.
It doesn't dictate the
way we're going to do it,
but what it does is
it sets up a framework
to ensure collaboration
and improve transparency
so that we are making the
best decisions possible.
So the NROC and the
Northeast ocean plan
sets up that framework
for stakeholders
to better plan and
ensure safety, security,
environmental
protection in the area.
But we know that oceans
don't stop at state, local,
or national
boundaries, and I don't
think any symposium on the
oceans-- certainly not one
from sea to changing sea or a
presentation like this titled
"Future of the Oceans" would be
complete without a discussion
of the 1982 Law of
the Sea Convention.
I've got a number of
notes here, and I'm just
going to sort of
ad lib a little bit
because I've lived
this issue ever
since I've been a lawyer
in the Coast Guard.
Many of you know that
the United States is not
a party to the 1982 Law
of the Sea Convention.
The United States was the
catalyst for that negotiation
of that 1982 convention.
We were dissatisfied
with the 58 conventions.
They were good, but
they left many gaps
that needed to be addressed.
One of the most
important of which
was the breadth of
the territorial sea.
The other was the
rights and obligations
in the exclusive
economic zone, and issues
like how do you claim
sovereign rights
over an extended
continental shelf.
For most of the convention, it
was considered a huge victory
for the United States.
There were some
serious deficiencies
in what's called Part 11 of the
original agreement, the Deep
Sea Mining Provisions.
There were forced
technology provisions.
President Reagan
was not satisfied
that the size of the
international seabed authority,
both its size and the authority
to act would be kept in check.
So in 1994, we were able to
conclude a separate agreement
on Part 11 that fixed all
the issues that President
Reagan was concerned about.
Now keep in mind those
were only very narrow
issues that moved the United
States away from signing
the convention at that point.
Those issues were fixed in
'94, but despite the fact
that those were
addressed, we still
have not been able to get this
convention over the finish
line.
The convention has 166 countries
including the European Union.
Yet, we've not yet ratified it.
Now the importance
of the convention
is that it sets up the
international framework
for cooperation on
peaceful uses of the ocean.
This is the umbrella over which
all Maritime activity should
take place-- peaceful
Maritime activity.
There are comprehensive
provisions
on marine environmental
protection,
marine environmental research.
It locks in rights concerning
freedom of navigation that
are critically important to us.
It secures the limits
of the territorial sea.
It is foundational.
We apply it as customary
international law.
I think we need to move forward
and accede to the convention
so that we can
assert those rights
and protections on the strongest
legal footing possible,
and that is treaty law.
And I'm happy to talk
about that and questions.
In closing, let me simply
leave you with this.
We as a community are facing
extraordinary challenges
as ocean temperatures
and sea levels rise,
as marine life habitats change,
and government simply cannot
address this alone.
The calculus is much more
complex than one agency,
and the calculus cannot be
balanced unless we ensure that
the full continuum of
the equation meets its
responsibilities.
That full equation,
those critical factors
need to be validated
and totaled.
We must collaborate, we must
partner at different levels.
Even those of us
with disparate views,
we need to share
information and build
on each other's good
works, the good ideas,
and the good practices.
We need scientists
to analyze data
that industry and
government collects
so that we may do our
business smarter and better.
We need industry to comply
with environmental regulations
to help achieve long
term sustainability.
We need citizens to
continue to be vigilant.
It's like if you see
something, say something.
That applies to
Homeland Security,
but it implies the protection
of our oceans just as much.
We must work collaboratively at
all echelons-- local, regional,
and internationally.
We in the Coast Guard look
forward to working with you,
and I thank you so much
for this opportunity
to spend a little
bit of time with you
and I look forward to
answering your questions.
Thank you for a
fantastic symposium.
[APPLAUSE]
- I get to ask the
first question.
I'll just ask one
question and then
we'll turn it over
to the audience.
So here's my question.
10 days from now,
we're going to have
an election in this country.
Most people probably
know about that.
What you may or may not
know is that right now there
are two different
teams who are working
in charge of the
transition depending on who
wins the presidential election.
Chris Christie is
heading the transition
for the Republican
nominee Donald Trump,
and Ken Salazar is
heading the transition
on behalf of Hillary Clinton.
As part of the transition,
what will happen-- whichever
team's nominee
wins, they're going
to come to all parts of the
executive branch including
the Coast Guard.
And they're going
to ask you, what
are the pressing issues-- with
the new administration-- has
to address?
And so my question is when
the transition team comes
with the Coast Guard,
and if and when
they meet with you--
whichever team it is,
it should make no
difference which team it is.
Your reports should
be precisely the same.
What will you tell them?
What do you think the
Coast Guard should
tell them-- are
the pressing issues
the Coast Guard faces in
addressing the kinds of topics
we're talking about
here, and that's
going to be the oceans
and climate change.
- I guess the first thing--
thanks for the question.
I think the first
thing I would tell
them is based on everything
that you saw here,
you're going to need
a bigger Coast Guard.
[LAUGHING]
The other thing that
I would tell them
is that they must remain
committed to recapitalizing
the United States Coast Guard.
We're in the midst of
recapitalization efforts
for our deepwater fleet.
We are just led a contract
to procure 25 offshore patrol
cutters that will
project presence down
in the transit zone for
counter-drug primarily
and migrant
interdiction operations.
But it's about projecting
that effective presence
that I talked about
in the presentation.
The next thing that I
would tell them is they
need to commit to building
heavy icebreakers for the United
States.
I'm not going to say this
is a Coast Guard icebreaker
because it's a national asset.
I think many people
misunderstand that.
This is a national asset that
just happens to be painted red
and has a Coast
Guard stripe on it.
Most people don't
realize that the United
States has one medium
icebreaker that can only
operate in the Arctic
and only has one--
let me say that again--
one heavy icebreaker,
the Polar Star.
The Polar Sea, its
sister ship, is
welded to the dock in Seattle.
We had to take parts of it
to keep Polar Star running.
We are losing ground when it
comes to building icebreakers
to project effective presence
in the polar regions.
The next thing I
would tell them is
to ensure that we remain
focused on the Arctic.
It's an opening area.
We're continuing to see
increased man-made activity
and the Coast Guard will
be the Maritime presence
in the Arctic, and so we must
commit to a sustainable Arctic
presence.
- Thank you very much.
We'll take questions.
The price of asking a
question is you should first
introduce yourself.
- My name is David Arnold.
Good afternoon.
Who was holding out on
the 1982 treaty and why?
- There are a lot of
members of Congress
who believe that the
convention is not in the best
interests of the United States.
I think, and I'm just
going to generalize here
because I don't want to point
to any particular individual.
I'm just going to generally
talk about some of the concerns
that I've heard.
The first is I think there's
some misinformation out there.
The problems that plague
the 1982 convention
are still talked about as
reasons why we shouldn't join.
This convention is modified
by the Part 11 agreement.
So there's just
fundamental misinformation.
People talk about forced
technology sharing.
That's resolved.
There are other people who
don't like the mandatory dispute
resolution mechanisms.
However, if you look at
a lot of US agreements,
they have dispute
resolution mechanisms.
And so, I'm not sure
why we're shying away
from dispute resolution,
especially when we carve out
military activities,
law enforcement
activities, and other things
that just aren't going to be
subject to dispute resolution.
I think there is some
concern about paying
royalties for exploration in
the extent of continental shelf.
There's a scheme set up
through the convention
that if you have an extended
continental shelf, although you
get sovereign rights to that
extent of continental shelf
and I should say
parenthetically,
we believe that if we
follow the procedures
in the convention
which we now hold
is customary international law.
But if we went through the
process and the convention
and secured the greatest
legal footing possible,
we could claim an extended
continental shelf that's
probably twice the
size of California
or at least the size of
California-- it's huge--
and we would get
sovereign rights.
And that means the ability
to explore and exploit
those resources
beyond 200 miles.
But the convention
sets up a system
where you have to pay a
certain percentage of royalties
to the international
seabed authority,
and people just don't like that.
However, those provisions
were negotiated in large part
by the offshore industry
back during the conventions
negotiations.
They have no problem
with the royalty scheme.
In fact, the royalty scheme
only kicks in five years
after you start production.
A lot of wells are pretty
much exhausted by the time
you get to five years.
So those are just a few
reasons, and again there's just
some bad information out there.
Beyond just stale information,
just bad information out there,
for example I've heard
some people say it would
create a United Nations Navy.
There ain't nothing I've
seen that says that.
It says that no military
activities will be
subject to dispute resolution.
We know that's not true.
And I could go on
and on and on, but I
think what we tried to do a few
years ago when we were trying
to move it through the Senate
as an administration was
to correct any misperception
and to focus on what we see
is large strategic benefits
to the United States,
such as making sure that
we continue to project
global leadership
on ocean policy,
making sure that we can secure
those rights on the strongest
legal footing possible,
making sure that we can secure
and perfect title
to those resources
on an extended
continental shelf.
- I just want to
add a quick comment
to what the Admiral
said, and that is it
underscores the significant
voice the nation's military has
right now on a lot of fronts.
We have a national
government which
for decades has been
largely paralyzed
by partisanship
and by increasing
distrust of the government.
The nation's military
has a distinctively
reliable and credible
voice that can really
help break some of the logjams
on many of these pressing
issues.
- Hi, I'm Peter Girguis
from Harvard University.
Thank you for that presentation.
I have two questions.
I'll start with the easy one.
In light of your commitment to
appropriate resource management
and environmental
protection security,
have you considered running
for president-- question one?
And on a more-- on maybe
a more difficult note,
I've been part of the National
Science Foundation's council
that oversees the US
academic research fleet.
And one I can
absolutely corroborate
what the Rear Admiral said,
and that is the icebreakers
are a real problem.
That the US academic
community depends
on those icebreakers for
research in the polar regions,
and at this point it's
actually embarrassing
that we're at the
state we're at.
But the question I
have for you, sir,
is do you see an opportunity
to have academics engaged
with your more daily and routine
activities given that we've
lost about a third of our
academic research fleet
and given that
your ships maintain
a more substantial presence?
Do you see a way that we can
collaborate across agencies,
whether it's the US Coast
Guard and the National Science
Foundation or so on?
Thank you.
- Thanks for the question.
I absolutely do, and
I hope I mentioned
some of those in my remarks.
I think it's important for
the scientific community
and the academic community
to help us push technology,
to protect the oceans.
I mentioned oil spill detection.
We have real challenges now
with some of the heavier oils
that are being transported
that actually sink.
They don't float.
You can skim oil on
top of the surface
or you can clean it when
it hits the beaches.
It's hard to clean up oil that
has a specific gravity-- what
is it, greater than one?
Somebody help me with science.
Thank you, whew!
[LAUGHING]
- Chemistry major.
- But I think the other
thing that's very helpful,
and I'm going to speak as a
commander of the First Coast
Guard district who has a large
fisheries responsibility up
here in New England, and that
is to help us really develop
the kind of metrics that
we need to make sure
that our enforcement
actions are bearing fruit.
Not in terms of penalizing
the fishing fleet,
but in terms of
preserving the fish stock.
Is enforcement having an effect?
We can do it when we talk
about Coast Guard counterdrug
efforts.
We know generally how much
cocaine is produced worldwide.
We know how much we're catching.
We have good detection
and monitoring
so we know often
when the bad guys go
by because we just don't have
the resources to get them.
The equation is a little
bit easier in counterdrug.
It's not easy when it comes
to fisheries enforcement
because each fish
stock is different,
each species is different.
They're migratory and
I'm not sure we've
got the best possible
handle that we can
on what the nature
of the problem is.
I'm responsible for
putting Coast Guard
resources to use the most
effective way possible.
The only way I can
do that is if I
can circle back
and look at metrics
that say I'm having an effect.
It's hard for me to
do that in fisheries.
We're working on it within
the Coast Guard, but, wow,
wouldn't it help if academia
and scientists joined us
in that effort?
- I'm Tanya [? Vartanian. ?]
I'm a musician with interest
in the sciences.
I was wondering
how much the-- how
do you reconcile the
military experimentation that
goes on in the oceans
with preserving
the acoustical environment of
the sea mammals and other sea
animals?
I know there is a conflict
there that sometimes becomes
the subject of discussion.
- Yeah, you're not going to like
my answer to this because I'm
not the expert on
sonars and acoustics
because no Coast Guard
cutters have sonar.
We took sonars off years
ago, so we're not the experts
by any means.
Somebody correct me if the
new cutters have sonar.
I stand corrected.
But no, we're not the
experts on acoustics.
I mean, I listened to
the prior presentation
with great interest, but it's
not something that we focus on.
What I found more
applicable to us
were the commercial
vessel trends transiting
through the right
whale areas, and we
do enforce the
speed restrictions
to protect the right whales.
- Thank you.
- Sorry I didn't have a
better answer for you.
- Thank you very much.
- And with that, we'd like to
thank the Admiral, Richard.
[APPLAUSE]
So this has been a
delightful symposium
because of all the
amazing presentations
and great questions.
The first one was amazing.
I was really pleased
to learn about all
the different
metabolic pathways.
I will mention that one of the
poster session people, Joey
Nelson, did her dissertation
on sulfur-- bacteria that uses
sulfur as an energy source.
So you may want to see her.
The second panel looks--
it's somewhat sobering
to look at the effects of
temperature changes, especially
this number that-- I guess if
30% of the sea ice-- Arctic sea
ice is left, that means
that 70% has gone away.
And most of what is
remaining is not old ice,
but it's just new
ice and just seems
like we're looking
at a disaster there.
It also shows the
incredible heat capacity.
That little graph that showed
how much of the heat capacity
is in the atmosphere compared
to how much is in the ocean-- I
mean, I kind of knew
that conceptually,
but to see it
displayed was just-- it
really hit home to me.
So that was incredible.
We heard about very detailed
engineering strategies
about how to mitigate the
risks of sea level rise.
Because as we heard,
already the sea level rise
is baked into the atmosphere.
I mean, we can make choices
now about CO2 emissions,
but it's coming and so
we have to get prepared
and it's our decision
whether or not
it's going to get really
bad or whether or not
it becomes manageable.
So that was what we saw there.
And then the third
panel-- again,
the effects of global warming.
I caught a sea bass over
the summer off of Cape Cod,
and we looked at it
and said, what's this.
And we had to get
our little thing.
And then the first thing he says
was, yeah, it's global warming.
And then we tossed
it back and I just
realized it was global warming.
So, thanks.
It's impressive the stress that
we're putting on New England
biomass out there, and
I think next time I
hear I have to stay away
from a right whale area,
I'll definitely be doing it.
And finally, I think
with the closing talk
by the Admiral and just looking
at the diversity of ways
of looking at this,
it just gets me back
to at least a somewhat
hopeful state.
I mean, when I was
in the Marshalls,
as I opened up the talk,
I realized that we really
are highly dependent on
protecting the ocean,
and all of us have to think
about becoming protectors
of the ocean because
it's something
that affects all of us.
And I hope the symposium
today brought home that,
and as you go home you start
to reflect on what you heard
and how you may
contribute in some way.
So thank you all and
enjoy the reception.
[APPLAUSE]